so now that I have my episodic memory
framework and I have all the necessary
pieces of information that I've
extracted from the original piece of
content what I can do is I can review it
which is actually the most important
thing everything leads up to this moment
most modern languages are estimated to
have vocabularies ranging in the
hundreds of thousands of words if you're
learning a language you will need to
find a way to commit anywhere from a few
hundred to a few thousand of those words
to memory
that sounds like a lot of work and it is
but I know a secret that has helped me
build a large vocabulary in over a
thousand languages without taking up too
much of my time and too much of my
energy a secret that can help you do
exactly the same for your own target
language
hi I'm Lucas I'm a Language Coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages
faster more efficiently and in a fun way
let's Dive Right In
so what's the recipe for building a huge
vocabulary in a foreign language
before you can get started you need
three things one a portable notebook and
something to write with two authentic
target language content that's well
suited to your level and three my six
rules for memorizing new vocabulary okay
okay I know that's eight things but the
first two are relatively easy all things
considered all you have to do is grab a
small notebook like this and some good
content in your target language how to
get good target language content is a
topic for another video but for the sake
of Simplicity let me just make a few
quick recommendations for beginners I
recommend content from asimos with ease
course books or Innovative language pod
101 or class 101 series for intermediate
Learners I recommend any short podcast
or YouTube video that catches your
interest once you have your notebook and
your content you can then just get into
the meat of memorization my six rules
for remembering words in any language
these rules are Mark highlight or
underline what you want to remember
transfer the most important Expressions
into your notebook store just enough
Expressions to remember the gist of the
content connect stored Expressions to
the context in which they were learned
translate the Expressions into your
native language and review your notebook
regularly
rule number one Mark highlight or
underline what you want to remember
when I go through a piece of content in
my target language be it an article
dialogue or even the script of a podcast
or video the first thing I do is Mark
highlight or underline any word or
phrase that seems interesting to me or
particularly relevant to my life here's
what that looks like in practice so I
have here in front of me is the audio
and the text of a podcast for people who
want to learn German this is a fantastic
resource for people who have let's say
an A2 level but the language doesn't
matter what I want to show you is how I
Mark interesting words and sentences
within a certain piece of content now
I'm showing you the setup so pencil
highlighter text audio and computer
anti-stress ball and
pencil sharpener water and coffee
just for the sake of presenting the the
normal setup but for the sake of this
video I'm going to show you how I Mark
these words and I'm not going to play
the audio I'm just going to read through
I'm gonna translate into English and
then I'm going to show you what words I
normally take into account and Mark and
how I do that so without further Ado
let's get started
clima shoots in the Disco so this is the
title of the podcast
protection on the environment literally
this means in the in in in a club or in
collapse
so Pauline is
Berlin is known for its club scene okay
this is interesting but I don't feel
like marking any word here yet
now politicians want to make sure that
the clubs of the capital become Greener
so in this case
does so make sure that this is
interesting so first I put them in
parenthesis as you've seen here and then
I create let's say a connection again
I'm using a pencil and I'm gonna say I'm
gonna write here make
sure that
I find this a very interesting and
useful expression so I just marked it so
next Ani is
an idea or one idea is for example a
transfer dancing floor Tans means tanzo
Tansen means to dance surface so that's
the dancing floor deep
byzant that while dancing
uh generates electricity current this is
literally storm is current so
um I like storm outside okay so you see
how far I've put this here
this is for reasons uh that you will see
also in other videos
I'm using this space all this this blank
space on the page to put to add more
information so generate
electricity
then you have yellowish
Berlin every year thousands of tourists
come Austin
so both from Germany inside of Germany
and from abroad in the Deutsche abstract
Berlin
maybe ausland abroad I can write it here
abroad this they put it just next to it
foreign
this is a very long word this means
basically sites or places of interest
interesting places within the you know
within a certain place
so I'm just going to write means to
visit so to visit sites
it's an interesting word here and
to learn something about the history of
the city
Android
others who come because of the various
so many various auske means to go out
means possibilities so basically this
means
you know possibilities of going out
nightlife nightlife possibilities
I'm abandon
in the evening Napoleon to Berlin
and here oh this is interesting
you know so I'm just gonna write here
night
life possibilities
the club scene there is international
internationally known and this literally
means very appreciated very light
but
however the clubs are not exactly
umbelt
foreignly so environment environmental
friendly ecological I would say
means to the country so here you get an
idea how I go through a text and I just
Mark words or interesting sentences here
has marked just one word single word
ausland abroad here is
to make sure that
and of course if you want to you can
always use for example a highlighter so
you can highlight this
you can like this you can highlight this
this this
etc etc this is how I Mark a text and
you can see
we have one two one two three let's say
two three Expressions per paragraph and
again
let's say that I abide by the criteria
of
what is relevant for me what is interest
what what Peaks my interest within this
piece of content
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
rule number two transfer the most
important Expressions into your notebook
after I've marked highlighted or
underlined all of the Expressions that I
think I want to remember I then take a
subset of those expressions and transfer
them into my portable language learning
notebook to be more specific I distill
my list of Expressions down to the most
useful words and phrases and then write
them down in the notebook let's see how
this works in practice
so once I've marked all the expressions
and the words that I find interesting
relevant within this piece of content
the next step is to transfer these
pieces of information into my notebook
and as you can see here my notebook is
pretty small compared with the side of
my hand and I gave it here a title so
you have here a label I put here German
and then it opens like a book you can
see here the first page I normally leave
it blank
and then I have this structure we have
this structure here so we have
um on the left I can put some pieces of
information a given amount and a certain
specific type of information and on the
right another kind of information and as
you will see in a second I will show you
how I transfer the notes what kind of
notes I transfer and how I structure
them into this notebook another
important thing to take into account
again is that I find this very visually
Pleasant I really like this kind of
notebook here from the cover to the
inside and as you can see it's small
enough that it can fit in my pocket so I
tend to choose things that are portable
and I tend to take this with me carry
this with me all the time so step number
three I'm going to transfer now all the
contents into this small notebook and
again I'm going to select the pieces of
content that I find interesting now I'm
not going to select all of them just a
part of them but I want to make sure
that they're dense enough so that I can
reconstruct the meaning and the gist of
this piece of content by reading just
the notes from this notebook I'm going
to leave a space here and I'm going to
explain to you why in a little bit so
without further Ado let's get started
the first thing that I want to write is
politica volun adafius
politica
vollen
Darfur
zorgen which means politicians
want
to make sure
that
and the second one that I'm going to
choose is
to generate
electricity
I can write tourism
common
ausland
so tourists
come
from
abroad
the continent
the content
zines
heightened
to visit
well-known
places of interest or sites
hkaden so here I can write
foreign
so various
night
life
options
literally means possibilities
according to
cording
two here we have zofi Strom but again I
just wrote I just uh marked stolen so
I'm just gonna skip that unbeaten I'm
gonna skip it
I'm gonna skip that uh
to reduce
the amount
of
water actually this means fabwell who's
the the use of water
more than amount but that's that's okay
and then I'm Gonna Keep continue and I'm
just gonna write a couple of other
things here
the notes that I jutted down are dense
enough that they help me reconstruct the
sequence of ideas within this piece of
content so if I go from the first
expression to the last that I jutted
down here I should get a good idea of
how the content flows and that's also
the reason why I decided to put for
example a subject here instead of just
saying
does I just wrote politica volenderfield
song So politicians want to make sure
that because the subject is going to
help me reconstruct the idea it's always
a good idea to have for most of these
um most of these pieces of information a
subject to reconstruct the idea so here
I have politicians are making sure that
generate electricity tourists come from
abroad to visit known sites
various nightlife options according to
this I liked this doesn't have I like
this expression doesn't have a noun here
but it doesn't matter this leaves a
little bit of flexibility for when I
want to reconstruct for example a piece
of content reduce the use of water
sustainable dancing floor to save energy
gets financial support I remember I
didn't even write Financial but I know
that this is get financial support reach
many people become a model
rule number three store just enough
Expressions to remember the gist of the
content when you're choosing which
important Expressions to store in your
notebook it's beneficial to store just
the right amount of Expressions neither
too many nor too few how can we
determine the right amount of
expressions for a piece of content you
need to store just enough expression so
that when you review them later you're
able to recall the gist or main ideas of
the entire piece of content I'd like to
refer to this as density if your
selection of stored Expressions is
appropriately dense it contains the cues
necessary to help you remember most of
the concepts contained in your text
podcast or YouTube video
are probably dense nodes also help you
remember the sequence of ideas within
the piece of content if you can go from
your first expression to your last and
get a good idea of how the content
flowed then you're done a fantastic job
and we'll remember these Expressions
much more easily let me show you what
dense notes look like the next step is
to transfer apart a portion of the
pieces of information that I deem
important or relevant and interesting
from this piece of content into my
notebook now I'm going to leave a space
here and you will understand why in a
little bit and I'm going to transfer
some of these pieces of information into
my notebook so for example
politica
vollen
Darfur
zorgen
Das
politicians want to make sure that
storm
to generate electricity
to Reston tourists
common Come house
team
ausland they come from abroad tourists
come from abroad
known
s
chitin
bizugan
to visit known places of interest or
sites
gay
chitin nightlife options and I can add
your name to various
then I have
here which sounds interesting
according to
zofil strong this is a piece of content
I'm going to skip because I already have
stolenath song
then I'm beaten I'm gonna skip that one
as well and again
also I'm gonna skip that
again I'm just I'm just jotting down
um
a portion
February
so to reduce
the amount reduce the consumption of
water this is interesting for me
so this means sustainable dancing floor
so I'm gonna write that
this is interesting for me the inagi
span to save energy
the common
on
feeder Lloyd
to reach a lot of people
and then
um
active
Sovereign to become active and Ein
for build
en
to become a model rule number four
Connect stored Expressions to the
context in which they were learned
one problem most people face when
writing down words and phrases to
remember is that when they look at their
notes later they cannot actually
remember where any of this information
came from our memories are built like
networks so if you can keep the
Expressions you're learning well
connected to the context in which you
learn those expressions you'll have a
powerful way to recall them whenever you
need to
let me show you how I keep my
Expressions connected to their contexts
foreign
principle when it comes to then
reviewing these words is that the words
and the Expressions that you draw down
here should be dense enough so that you
can reconstruct the gist of the piece of
content from where these pieces of
information were originally extracted
that's also one of the reasons why for
example instead of just writing a volun
Duffield zogin does they want to make
sure that I also added politica because
if say I'll review this in a month I
will not remember
who we're doing what if I don't add
exactly the noun that this expression or
this verb refers to so remember that you
want to transfer enough pieces of
content not too many otherwise this
becomes pretty heavy but at the same
time you want to make sure that they're
dense enough and they're they have the
quality that you need in order to
reconstruct the gist of the original
piece of content that you extracted them
from
another very important principle in
order to make this kind of exercise and
this notebook very noteworthy and
worthwhile is to add context so if you
take a look at these pieces of content
say three months from now you're going
to be asking yourself what do these
pieces of content refer to so here a
simple thing a simple action that you
can do is to add and give a title so you
can just write for example here clima
shoots
in their Discord and then you can also
write maybe the source Deutsche
deutschevela and if you want you can
write a date here and this gives very
valuable context I call this episodic
memory framework because it gives you a
framework which is going to help your
episodic memory where where did you
extract these from and when did this
happen this I can assure you is really
really good when it comes to memorizing
and in general committing pieces of
content that you extract into your
long-term memory rule number five
translate the Expressions into your
native language if you look at my
notebook here you'll notice that it
opens horizontally with one page on the
left and one page on the right this is a
deliberate Choice having two pages of
notes next to each other like this makes
it useful to practice my next rule which
involves translating my stored
Expressions into my native language
here's an example from my own notebook
the reason why I choose notebooks I have
the structure is that I can put not only
the pieces of information in my in my
target language but also in my native
language so I can add the translation of
all these pieces of content on the right
side so that I have a bird's eye view of
pretty much everything that I extracted
from this piece of content so let me
translate these sentences sentence by
sentence
rule number six review your notebook
regularly once you've stored all of your
notes according to the previous rules
you'll have reached the most important
step of the process actually reviewing
everything you wrote down
this might sound boring but it's
essential if you don't review your
stored Expressions regularly you will
never remember them reliably enough to
actually use them and if you cannot use
them then well what's the point here's
how I use my notebooks to review the
Expressions I write down in my target
languages
so now that I have my episodic memory
framework and I have all the necessary
pieces of information that I've
extracted from the original piece of
content what I can do is I can review it
which is actually the most important
thing everything leads up to this moment
the bulk of the work has been done
before but now that you have all these
pieces of common of content you have so
many creative ways in which you can
review for example here you can see well
you can feel how light it is and how
small it is so I can hold it with my
left hand or with my right hand I can
put it here
I can simply read this out loud for
example let me give an example
does maybe you can even add something
here if you want to
you can add here a noun if you want to
or you can form a sentence out of this
piece of content which is a frame which
is a just a phrase generate electricity
so you could add for example dancing
floor generates electricity
tourists come from abroad so you can
just simply read them out loud you can
read them and complete them you know you
can add more things that's the reason
why it's very important that you you
don't write simple words but you don't
write long complete sentences you want
to keep it
keep these sentences keep these phrases
short enough so that you have
flexibility and you can play around you
can see that they're dense enough so you
can reconstruct the whole story you can
reconstruct a piece of con the original
piece of content or you can also for
example given the fact that you have the
text in your native language here this
is of course in English I wrote it in
English
but whatever your native language is you
can cover the part in your target
language and by reading these you can
try to reconstruct you can try to
remember actually this is called recall
you can try to recall what these
sentences are and there are also
um
a lot of other really creative and cool
ways in which you can use this you can
use these pieces of content in order to
self-talk and I will talk about this in
another video and this is also one of
the most powerful techniques I've
developed in the last years and it is in
my overcoming the intermediate Plateau
course and students love it that's it
these are the rules I follow to memorize
words in any language if you put these
to use you'll be well on your way to
memorizing as many words as you need to
Let's recap everything I talked about
First grab a notebook and some quality
language learning content after that
follow my six powerful rules for
memorizing words Mark highlight or
underline what you want to remember
transfer the most important Expressions
into your notebook store just enough
Expressions to remember the gist of the
content connect stored Expressions to
the context in which they were learned
translate the Expressions into your
native language and review your notebook
regularly if you'd like more information
about how I incorporate memorization
into my language learning routine
including super cool ways to use your
store notes for speaking practice then I
recommend checking out the second course
in my become a master language learner
series titled overcoming the intermedia
Plateau I've left a link about it down
in the description box
thanks for watching and as always happy
language learning